[Music]
when i was a kid we lived about a mile a
mile and a half from school and
oftentimes i would walk and on the way
home from school my favorite stop to
make was the coin shop
it was a little nerd haven i loved it
they had football cards i was really
into football cards baseball cards of
course but i wasn't so much into those
and coins obviously it's called the coin
shop and the proprietor proprietor of
said shop was um an older guy he was
probably
my age now
no no he was older than that really he
was wisdomed he was more wizard he was
with um but he reminded me of the guy in
the neverending story remember who he
gets the book from
and uh the guy said now be careful
there's a lot of power in that book he
was a little bit like that but he never
gave me any like magical trinkets a
little like peter falkey
yes yeah yeah a little bit he looked
like dennis franz remember
yeah i just took her did oh my god and
he'd be behind the counter all the
really valuable stuff was like under
glass for me was like being in a museum
so i treated it that way and i think
that's pr in retrospect that's probably
why he was a little surly with us kids
you know it was like it was your good
place maybe one of the best places but
it was definitely a good place
could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for sure i'm
your host that good host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
uh with me as always is um
my critical brother christian so what
was your good place
as a kid well i like the coin shop too
where did you get there
football cards yeah i wasn't into coins
yeah that was a nerd bridge too far you
know but i you say that
it was a nerdy thing to do which
i would argue in a positive way i don't
mean to be no i know but i would argue
that kids who are into
football cards and coins and stuff like
that i wouldn't classify as that as
nerdy i think adults who are into that i
would say that's nerdy uh you know what
i'm saying it's like just being a kid
like what kid isn't into
football cards and maybe just because my
friends were not i mean i guess coins
are pretty nerdy no matter how old you
are
it was all you know it's funny because
like it doesn't really suit my
personality being so into like the
meticulous nature no of those coins but
i was i was no it's like you would think
you'd grow up to be into jewelry or
watch oh i hate that [ __ ] i know unless
it's a sponsor
um
yeah i but i was i was into like the it
is weird it is right it's not consistent
i just thought it was so cool that um
these things like also into money like
that well you also coveted things more
as a kid
like football cards but what was your
thing that you want what was the
football card that you wanted more than
anything
um i think it changed i i always wanted
uh a jerry rice rookie card i didn't
have one no i had a second his second
year i know i didn't you know what i
1986. see i hoarded those i had a couple
of them you don't have brookies yeah are
you sure cherry rice yeah yeah it's a
cheerio counter speaking of maybe that's
why i said it like that we're talking
about a cherry maybe man are they
different cherry rice and o'connell
they're both athletic i guess i guess so
and i don't know jerry rice maybe he is
personality-wise more or some why
wouldn't i say that anyway um yeah i had
a couple to brag and i had a couple
cherry rice rookies and i i really
wanted a joe montana rookie
those were those are hard to come by um
why are we you know what else they had
there was candy yeah and and the
football cards used to have a stick of
stale gum yes remember it was like a
powdery it was like powdery gum that
crumbled it was so gross but i would
always eat it me too because i did not
not but injustice yeah well sometimes i
would ingest it by mistake cause
remember when you would when you chew it
it would immediately like within 40
seconds go down to the tiniest little
piece
yeah remember that it was like it was
such a gross gum and i remember you told
me that gum that the human body can't um
digest gum so that every time you
swallow gum it builds up into a big
mouth i had heard that in your body i
heard that from someone ever since you
told me that i never swallowed gum again
isn't it funny there may be i just
realized there may be fewer wives tales
now
these are why do you call them wife
sorry or spouse tales um old spouse
tales
that's because um elderly spouse tales
yeah because um
uh because of the internet because those
were things that just got passed down as
as truth like oh i'm trying to think oh
if you handle a toad you'll get warts
of course we now know that that is not
true that's not scientifically you might
get sick you might pick up other things
that parasites whatever but you won't
get warts just because they have warts
so you think the internet overall has
been good for
facts uh
oh well think about it that way think
about all the disinformation that's on
there i know but but just in terms of
wives tales old wives sales
i feel like
is that offensive to say now you're not
allowed to say that old wives i don't
know elderly spouse
allegedly aged spouse tales but because
a thing like that uh that we were just
talking about
you can now look it up that's true also
did you hear the one where we like
swallow a certain amount of spiders i've
heard that is that true i've also heard
that a certain number of people die in
hammock related deaths every year and
since i think that's true
i've been afraid to oh really lion
hammocks i also heard that daddy not
afraid i'm not psychotic right yeah i've
seen you
like those put those um those ropey
hammocks
those
those are a little you know so those
used to be a good place for you and they
no longer are the best place but they're
still there i love a good hammock yeah
so it can be a good place a nice a nice
book on a nice breezy summer day yes why
are we talking about good places good
question
um
our guest today
our more than good guest today is one of
the stars of the hit nbc show the good
place it's no longer on tv right it was
on for four years yeah and it was a
massive hit four good years great years
and it's now on netflix you can see it
anytime you want you can binge the [ __ ]
up
so darcy was like you said one of the
stars an emmy nominated star darcy
cardin yeah did you say her name i don't
know well uh now i have
yeah also people read it on the thing
that's right darcy cardin yes nominated
for
emmy
nme
nominated for emmy rossum
uh emmy's favorite casper for the good
place so you met her a few months back
you were you worked with her right yeah
speaking of first time meeting speaking
of good places i got to go back to work
briefly it was such a tease i got to do
three days on a um a show called creep
show a show called creep show
in atlanta georgia and darcy and i
played um a couple
uh and i it's a really fun episode of
this show on shutter i don't know anyway
uh it's coming out soon and the
legendary greg nicotero directed it and
darcy i had never um worked with i had
never met but i've been hearing so much
about her
uh through friends namely paul downes
who we'll talk about again
paul uh was one of the creators of broad
city and so darcy's name has come up
several times among my friends circles
and
always so glowingly and um people just
love her and now i see why i mean the
second i like within a couple minutes of
meeting her i understood the hype that
card and hype well i can't wait ah she's
great and yeah and you're all about to
hear her how great she is so why don't i
just let her talk
why am i mansplaining how great she is
because you're a man yeah you're
explaining okay
well here she is um so
get get in a good place get a nice comfy
good place and listen to the very funny
the great more than good darcy garden
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello
[Music]
i've been crying all morning justin why
have you been crying my husband jason
and i
have a great dog named penny
she's six
and we
have been toying with the idea actually
all quarantined but have really just um
kicked it up a notch about adopting
another dog oh yeah and we and
i guess long story short is a few weeks
ago we decided we wanted a puppy we
wanted to adopt a pit bull puppy i've
i've been like looking like a maniac at
all the different rescues i follow on
instagram and we had a like a meet and
greet with one yesterday
truly the
cutest
i mean just gorgeous so cute perfect
little puppy
we hung out with this dog for two hours
in our backyard and penny and this dog
played hard and it was great and
and and jason and i were like let's
sleep on it let's talk about it think
about it and then in the morning we both
woke up and we were like
i don't think that's okay
really yeah
it's like a feeling it's just a feeling
he his energy is really different than
pennies and penny's pretty mellow and
this guy had like puppy energy times a
million he was like
more than just puppy energy it might be
like he's just a a hyper boy a yeah
rambunctious a rambunctious yeah i saw
some post again from some rescue that i
follow that just i they never post stuff
like this but it said like don't adopt a
dog for your dog like do it only if you
want to oh and then you got in my head
about that and i'm like am i doing this
for her am i doing this for us anyway it
was one of those mornings where um
i couldn't stop crying so i'm look i'm
glad this is a pc podcast because my
eyes they're puffy
now that you mention it i can see that
all right
was
in a pretty way there you you look like
you've been crying in a pretty way like
a disney princess yes yes yes yes not
unlike because disney princesses cry
they look so pretty why were you crying
though is it just like i miss i'm
the thought of not having that dog that
you had so much fun with i'm it's just a
thing of like am i making the right
decision am i or jason and i making the
right decision
it's you know when you want to make a
life change
it's so easy to not do it right i mean
even adopting one dogger or having kids
i don't know you and i don't know that
but like you know there are
certain things moving dating whatever
where you're like yeah i could make this
life change that will probably be hard
the reward like what what's the balance
and then like is it easier to just not
you know well it's funny we talked about
this a little bit in atlanta like the um
when you when you're weighing that thing
whatever it is and i wonder if you feel
this way i don't feel this tremendous
void i don't feel the sense of like i
don't have something
we're very lucky to have to be able to
default to that but then does it also
make you
prevent you from making
a decision like getting a puppy that
might really bring joy to your life
and that's kind of the conversation
jason and i were having this morning
which is like the good news is
we love our life you know but then we
were thinking back to when we adopted
penny and the easier thing it was we
adopted her in the
man i really love saying adopted don't i
still like
god when i adopted my rescue pitbull
like jesus but when we got penny it was
in the sort of middle of my first season
of the good place like i don't know why
we did that and the easier thing would
have been to not do it
and just to wait or or wait until that
we had like a big break but we did it
when we did it and it has been like one
of the best decisions we've ever made
big old life decisions like that are
just so hard and um
you want someone to tell you what to do
i know it's funny we're wired very
similarly i think too because i i come
from a family that has a hard time
making decisions i think we are we i
think decisions are hard and you and i
we are wait
go see perfect example
you i know i was gonna say like that was
one of the first things
that i noticed about you
when we met this summer was this summer
this fall who knows god not that long
ago at all a few months ago was how
similar we are
yeah the good pla i started so i started
watching the good you were right
it is binge worthy
i thought it i thought you would like it
there's part of it that feels like ahead
of its time it also feels so you're
right i remember you telling me it's um
so philosophical and um there's like
existentialism that it explores morality
and what is good and was that one of
those scripts that you were like oh god
please like would you know right away
that that was special it wasn't that i
got the script and i thought i have to
get this job because they didn't even
give scripts out for the audition
because it was i mean any if you've
watched any of it there's twists in
every
in every episode but especially the last
um the finale of the first
season is a huge twist it makes sure the
creator was really trying to
do everything he could possibly do to
make sure that it wasn't leaked or it
wasn't there you know people didn't know
the twist to make sure to make oh really
good really good
no i do i do that to him all the time
he's like yeah i get it oh really yeah
i'll be like are you sure and he's like
yeah i'm sure and i'm like yeah yeah
buddy and he's like you do it every time
but anyway
yeah when the audition came my way and
it said you know um a mixture
show starring kristen bell and ted dance
and that was that alone was like right
but let me tell you something justin
yeah there was no world in which i was
getting this show do you know what i
mean this was just another
audition that i was getting as like a
struggling actor that would be you know
one that you cross your fingers for but
you ultimately don't get and it goes to
like you know your whatever celebrity
wants to do tv that day or whatever yeah
yeah like my biggest dream would be to
get this show but i i truly didn't think
for one second until i got like
the call back to do the actual test that
it was possible that i could get it so
dars does that make you better at the
audition or more
like how are you with that kind of is
that less pressure or more pressure
i think because there was nothing yeah i
think it's less pressure yep because i
it wasn't a possibility of getting it so
the point
of working hard on this audition was
truly just to like impress mike sher in
the room with the hopes that like
maybe i'll be the
girl that works at the coffee shop and
gets to like say two lines like that's
where i was in my career for real for
real wow had you done broads but
and i'm trying to place where you were
had you done broad city yet that's what
i'd done yeah and that's pretty much it
though you know like my
career it was i came up at ucb in new
york with
past guests like alana and abby and
um from broad city and so my
focus and career and
training and and day-to-day life was was
doing shows doing comedy shows at ucb
and it's really easy to sort of like get
tunnel vision there
where you get a little obsessed with
doing shows there
and and that becomes like that becomes
the whole world the whole like creative
entertainment world yeah yeah it's like
a little microcosm hmm i don't think
i've ever said microcosm before it feels
good doesn't it oh yeah but it's like
it's like hollywood but in one little
theater where you're like auditioning
and trying to i mean not hollywood but
you know just anything where you're
trying to get ahead so you kind of
forget about like oh i could be
making money at this somewhere you know
like i could actually be like trying to
get on tv shows but instead you're like
trying to get on a weekend team or
whatever and you really in it and
because
it was so great and exciting and such a
fun place to to come up and you know the
funniest people on earth were there it
really felt worth it like it really felt
like you were doing something you know
after ucb or during ucb i got broad city
and that was directly because two of my
best friends created the show and my two
my other best friends were writers and
directors on the show so they were like
they really gave me like a shot on that
show
one or two episodes this season which
was huge for me huge huge and are you
doing a supplemental job at this at this
point are you
waiting tables or doing any other
non-ucb stuff yes the answer to that is
like so many supplements supplemental
jobs waiting tables
temping
babysitting the main one was babysitting
that like nannying became a really good
way to make money and sort of have a
flexible schedule oh wait wait wait
you're probably sick of talking about
this but that's when you yeah we're the
nanny to
checks notes bill hater bill hader
yes i'm not sick of talking about it
good yeah phil so how did that how what
was that because bill has a bunch of
kids right yeah he has three didn't it
kind of sound though like you were
saying i was his nanny like he needed a
nanny
oh is that not what it was that is for
bill haters his kids oh yes well that
makes more sense
yeah bill um hater and maggie carrie um
i was their nanny for many years and and
you know still super close with them and
their kids and
um
they were my my family they were like
i'm meaning my
i
i
almost i don't know i practically lived
with them i was with them every single
day what is that like darcy when you get
that i've always wondered this about
nannies when you get that close to the
because you must have been really
obviously close with the kids and um
how talk about like i mean for somebody
who cried after spending two hours with
a pitbull puppy
what is it like
when you then leave that job and now
you're on the good place or whatever and
you no longer work there yeah i mean
that is it's so
rewarding
to nanny for a family that you
absolutely love and think of as you know
your family
and then it's so painful when you have
to like
leave them it's such a weird
thing to because you know you're with
them every day or or you know many times
a week or whatever it is
there was a while where
maggie was making a movie and i moved to
la with them for four months or
something so like it really is an
everyday thing
they treat you like family and it's just
like your world and then when it it was
yeah like a little heartbreaking when i
when we were how many years were you
with that family bill's family maybe
five or six
wow
i think maybe more
and you
do you keep in touch with them
afterwards oh yeah
totally i mean
a lot you know we go jason is also
really close with them so we go see them
a lot pre-pandemic but also just like
get i'll get a text from the oldest one
that's like can we face time
i think it sort of became like a aunt
uncle you know relationship
which is great well what is it like then
on the flip side is that do you have you
experienced the
family that maybe you're not obviously
you don't say it but um
have you
felt
the opposite of that oh yeah totally i
mean because i was
my
sort of goal with when i discovered that
nannying was like a good way to you know
make money in new york was my thought
was i will babysit for as many families
as possible so that no one counts on me
no one relies on me so that i'm not with
one family every day so that if i get an
audition or i get a anything i can just
drop them you know no one's like relying
on me just leave the kids at the park
yeah but you know like the night before
if i say hey i can't come in they're not
like but but but you're you know you're
the our only are your only hope obi-wan
is that right justin i don't know uh yes
thanks for deferring to me and knowing
that i'm a nerd and should know that
uh you're only hope
obi-wan yes but something like princess
leia says yes yeah yeah at least the
gist
something along those lines that's the
name
were you for some reason i feel like you
were a star wars fan though when you
were a kid i
i i wasn't not but i wasn't like you
know i like i watched all the movies
with my parents and
and
and i really liked like you know the
funny characters i was into like the
ewoks and [ __ ] yeah yeah r2d2 yeah you
know the funny ones the funny ones yeah
r2d2 the jawas oh jaws i think javas
yeah yeah come on you know like cutting
open that big dude and getting inside
sleeping that's funny
siblings kissing like all that stuff i'm
so into that you have three siblings i
didn't know that yeah i do speaking of
siblings kissing yeah
where's your where are you in the lot in
the order i am
second older sister lainey me younger
brother will younger sister miranda okay
miranda will laney great names and and
darcy my i told my mother we passed by
the street we were driving
upstate and we passed by street that it
was darcy avenue i was like i have a
friend named darcy and she and she said
does she spell it with an apostrophe and
i said yeah she does and she goes good
the right way
wait are you guys irish
no
no we're uh no italian and yeah german
and but but she said that was that was
the irish spelling yeah yeah
and she said disney's from she said we
went to we went to isney she went on a
whole run about how she went to isn't he
in ireland where disney's from and but
your then i read your the apostrophe was
a tribute to smashing pumpkins yeah yeah
okay you really read the story okay
i was born just regular old d-a-r-c-y
yeah easy to write easy to write easy to
say there's no question yeah and yeah it
was it there actually isn't much of a
story other than in junior high i was
like obsessed with
i guess just grunge music in general but
i really i loved smashing pumpkins and
the bassist darcy retzky had a um she
just was like i mean think back to like
i guess rock and roll in general but
grunge music there weren't a lot of gals
doing it right
yeah
you're i don't know you're there i mean
there were a handful but like like yeah
i mean i
did to whole yeah i remember apples
garbages garbages i love the cranberries
but you're right
so there were there weren't a ton and
especially maybe like a ton of anyway
there's just something about a bass
player with bleach blonde hair
she just was so cool and her name was d
apostrophe capital a rcy and i
just
changed it and never didn't change it
back that's okay
isn't that so great and then my parents
were like huh
because
it must it probably invites so many more
questions than than it needs to like
right oh are you irish right number one
right yeah it really yeah it's like um
unnecessary it's so unnecessary
but then
were they cool about you keeping were
they like okay yeah they were they were
um there was like a good lunch not
making fun of me but like my mom would
sign letters like m apostrophe o m for l
like kind of being like i could do it
too
um
but uh
i think there was a good long chunk of
time where they were kind of like
whatever weirdo and then it i think the
reason it never changed back is because
it just felt like that was my name i
don't even know how to explain it it
just was like this didn't feel like i
was
faking anything it felt i don't know
at a certain point it didn't feel
different oh nice good like
um yeah yeah were you
were you're did your siblings tease you
about it they were where was miranda
like oh okay dollar see i do remember
one time miranda um when she's 10 years
younger than me we're we're as close as
can be
and there is from from the time that she
was like a baby like i i don't we didn't
have that wait i don't know i keep
saying ten years she's nine years
younger than me but we didn't have that
like
you know
when when you have an adult or an older
sibling and you're kind of like
yeah more like more like an ant like
yeah we didn't have that hmm
how how close i needed are you guys
were like two yeah and older brothers
three so we definitely have that but
i've heard i know what you're talking
about like my mom is 10 years older than
her brother and they do i think it's a
little bit more of that
yeah that motherly thing but but closer
to that than a sister yeah and i don't
know why it didn't
it didn't do that i don't know why we
didn't do that but from from the time we
just
we connected really early on truly i
remember like when she was a baby i felt
like i get this girl but i anyway i
remember when i was in you know high
school or something i was
the um
teacher's assistant or something like
that for a drama class that she was in
like a summer drama class
and i um
she was so we were doing jungle book and
she had this small part but she was
really funny and
maybe it was two lines in a row let's
say it was like two funny things in a
row and she said the funny thing and it
got like a laugh from the audience and
then she looks out and she goes i love
this part and then did the next thing
and i remember being like damn that was
so funny
it killed she broke the fourth wall
yes she's basically she's like oh you
like that get ready for what i'm about
to say
yeah oh yeah i'm glad you're all sitting
down for this next line she's the she is
the funniest person in the universe
that's so great me do that like weird
like um i'm sure
you guys are the same right actually i
know you and your brother like this
where like
a nonsense sound or word or like
thought will make me cry laugh like she
she just she has my damn number you know
what i mean she just she gets it that's
so good what does she do what does she
do now she is a doula she lives in new
york
with um a great friend of mine her
husband it was a friend of mine and i
introduced them
oh
whoa oh
no kidding yes her husband let me unpack
this for a second take your time your
friend's husband
or the husband was a friend of yours
so
her husband nate dern i love him
he is he and i were on a herald team
together at ucb so we were like on a
house team together at ucb
oh i'm so sorry i thought it was worth
it
i divorced my husband and introduced him
to my friend she divorced him and my
sister snatched him up
no none of that
oh boring so it was just a friend of
yours and then they got together that's
it i probably explained it wrong but
yeah just a friend of mine i introduced
something you said it's salacious that
you said it like scandalously too yeah i
did i think i got excited um
so so miranda was too young to tease you
about that but uh when you changed when
you step when darcy darcy stuck
yeah was it just fetishizing like rock
and roll culture and like female
musicians stuff or did you pursue it any
further than that did you ever try to
play music like in junior high i
definitely had
you know got asked for a guitar for
christmas and i'll take lessons and
you know yeah i definitely had
aspirations to be a musician but it kind
of
i think it's actually my biggest regret
which i i'm not like a huge regret
person i don't like love living in
regret land but i that like thinking
back on i think you're the same yeah
guitar i wish i had learned guitar like
why didn't we do that and well
mine was because i was i didn't think it
was a possibility and i was playing the
violin which is not a good instrument to
play unless you're incredible at it
right and and the french horn which i
enjoyed but but guitar would have been
so
like really would have come in handy and
i've told i have told young people this
i sound like damn
elderly what i've told young people this
before like if you have
any
uh interest in playing guitar piano
whatever just do it truly just do it
like sign up for classes tomorrow
make yourself do it because you will
regret it like i mean i i remember
quitting
piano because i didn't like my teacher
and i remember like you know guitar kind
of hurt my fingers so i quit it's like
here i mean if it okay okay if anyone
young is listening to this without it
but okay the other thing about it like
not just when you're 10 or 12 or
whatever but then when i was 20 i was
like you know i should have played
guitar when i was 14 and now it's too
late and then when i was 30 i thought
you know i should have done it when i
was 20 and now it's too late it's a and
so i guess like should i do it now
should you do it now i don't know guess
so i mean it's like why is it too late
why is it too late in fact now is the
perfect time i was just saying like oh
god i'm dying to learn i saw this guy
doing american doing american sign
language and i'm like
yeah this guy's amazing
amazing right did you see him at the
press at the conference i only saw him
because you posted it oh my
god so expressive and crisp and fluid i
loved it yeah
and but now
chances are
i'm not going to pursue it i have this
real desire
what is that about i mean of course it's
like it's work it's effort it's like a
big undertaking it's not something
simple well it's like you said like
those major life choices you make a
choice that would be a choice to pursue
that like that's which would require a
certain degree of difficulty are we just
really lazy people i wonder
i also have i think tell me if you have
this i have a weird um actor thing where
i'm like
if i have to play a role like that i'll
really get into it but you know
absolutely like waiting for the role to
come to teach you to like yeah i'll
learn cello when i play a cellist but
like yes what what is that about well so
it's it's for something useful yes i can
commit it to film and people might see
it and like what i do what is that i
don't know i don't know but i but i uh
yeah the the or what we're about to say
well maybe it's just something that we
love i mean maybe it's like maybe i'm
not giving us us enough credit maybe we
love acting in that thing so much that
that's the ultimate goal that's like
that's the the the means to it's the
ultimate end right like that's what we
are doing something anything else for
that's what we're maybe that's why we
don't
have
kids maybe that's why i don't have a dog
maybe it's like
what if an acting job comes up i mean i
don't know we can really get into that
stuff at some point but i mean i think
you're on to something there for sure
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
so the good place audition really was
like holy [ __ ] i can't believe i'm
getting this audition even yes it was
definitely that it was like
yeah it was getting the audition was um
was uh very exciting i had just
gotten
this is all like
boring business talk but i had just
maybe like a month before um
fired a
manager which was a very scary thing to
do especially when you don't have like a
leg to stand on or whatever and gotten
especially when you're like a people
pleaser yeah yes for sure people pleaser
and also just like who am i to fire this
person you know but it was it was
clearly not
going well and then i'd gotten a new
manager who i'm still with and adore
justin letter big shout out to justin
i'm sure he's listening um i just got in
with this new manager and and was seeing
a lot more auditions and that even just
that alone was exciting this and so the
good place audition
was very exciting and i do have to say
in the same week was the berry audition
and and which which so i had gone from
like other than
um broad city which was like about an
episode a year given gifted to me by two
of my best friends
i was you know booking jack
shite
i think that's like german for [ __ ]
maybe okay that wasn't an actual show
the pilot on the violence the pilot for
jack shot yeah he's like a police man
he's like a detective um yeah he's a
german yeah
i play i play uh he's mistress but i'm
way older than him wait i had like they
really put a lot of like old age makeup
on me
so
so he's cheating on jane shite with you
yes and i'm like i was i'm like a 60
year old mistress
oh i i wish that show got picked up that
sounds like i know it was such a good
pilot
so and did barry come up and did the
audition for barry have anything to do
with with bill and having watched his
kids i think it came up like any
audition would and then when he saw that
i was on the audition list he texted me
like
but i you know i again where he's darcy
i just saw your name on
wow
is that nah everyone bill does everybody
so well he does no but he's very doable
like he has a very specific yeah that's
good yeah it's a yeah yeah yeah darcy i
noticed i noticed your uh
yeah no but it is that something it's
something there
um
i got the audition like a normal
audition but then when he knew i was
auditioning he sort of yeah there was a
weird moment to be honest justin where i
was like
do i
bow out of this audition should i like
text him and be like let's not worry
about this this is going to be weird
like i do you didn't want to put him in
a position where he felt yes i didn't
want to put him in a position where
he had to be like oh well we're clearly
not going to cast you person that never
gets cast in anything so we'll you know
i
but then i read that script and it was
so good and the role that i was going
out for i was i loved so much and and
had that
feeling which sometimes you have which
is like oh i could do this like i really
get this character so you get it and
you're like [ __ ] it i know this i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna go in there and
just do it it was a little bit of the
same feeling as the the good place one
where i just thought
because the other side of it is like
sometimes you get an audition for
something where you're like i am not
right for this but i'm gonna give it my
all i do not connect with this but here
we go but with with
janet and with
um natalie i had the this sort of like
rare feeling of like oh i think i can do
a good job in this in this audition so
i'm gonna do it
just to even impress the casting
director or just to impress make sure or
whatever so yeah so i thought at least
i'm not going to embarrass myself you
know in front of bill or whatever and
you know it all
it all freaking worked out
what was that like then in the wake of
that week so you get both of these
things
what do you think like what i
what was that like after because i don't
have that experience of
for the the time that you had been
laboring in that world and um you talked
about not having luck in that world what
did it feel like what like i know talk
me through that it was like um
it was so surreal and overwhelming and
exciting and just like a deeply good
feeling like like uh yeah jason and i
have been together forever and we've you
know we've been struggling in our
careers together and and
finding success in our careers together
so i just remember that day and like
that week kind of looking at each other
being like
you know like we a little bit of like we
did it that type of thing yeah and um
you know almost instantly lawyers and
managers and people get involved
and say like we don't know that this is
gonna work out you know i'm sure you've
been in that position where like
opportunities two jobs come your way all
the time you act like that but you come
on of course you have no but i i yeah
yeah
but then it becomes like oh [ __ ] yeah
you you fall in love with them both
totally it's like
and and where was the good place is all
it looks like a back lot like a very
well
art directed backlot which one was that
universal
oh it's like fun yeah it's back sort of
i think it's called like european square
or something like a little bit past jaws
and and um yeah it was really a lovely
lovely place to shoot oh yes i love it i
miss it at what point does being on the
good place when does it become when does
it change your
going out in the world life
how soon did that happen probably was
you know it was
i guess it was maybe a year or so after
it came out or god i wish i could
remember the timeline better but
it went to netflix and then it was like
it felt like everyone on earth watched
it the same night because then it was
like i mean
i
by the way
it's hardly anything i'm not i'm not
being like chase down the street or
anything but it would be you know like
at restaurants or or whatever just at a
party you know wow what did i just do to
my wrist i truly i went i like put my
hands on my waist and i twisted my wrist
i need to go to the doctor um
i
you know okay i don't mean to laugh
that's a that was a funny way to hurt
yourself i do have okay i don't know if
you can see this my wrists are
for being a big gal like i'm tall and
i'm i'm
athletic or whatever i have pretty small
wrists and they
i injure them all the time do you
dainty look at look at this
i hurt my wrists washing my face many
times washing my face what i like
pressing the towel against ow my wrist
it's insane it's insane
anyway okay wait so you ever break them
did
a single bone no kidding yeah when i
sometimes when i talk to you i feel like
i'm like on cocaine
because we bounce around it's like a
pinball yeah yeah that's a really great
trait with a uh on a podcast yeah
ping-pong all around
uh did you play sports darcy i did yeah
i do i do i didn't i do i did always
like in you know school and into high
school my main sports were basketball
softball and water polo those were my
sports holy [ __ ]
yeah police well water polo is that's
i've heard that's the most physically
demanding sport
i could believe that it really i mean it
will it's non-stop it's you never are
resting you know if you're in the water
yeah you're constantly moving treading
yeah it was amazing it was my favorite
sport yeah
but it was a sport you played like
yeah you played like in like varsity
like like competitive yeah babe i played
varsity i was the freaking captain all
righty
[Music]
but the thing about water polo which is
so weird is that i played basketball on
a coed league like up until a few years
ago i still play softball once i
graduated high school i never played
water polo again not for one second i've
never played it again and it was like
such a huge part of my life well that's
true because with water polo maybe i'm
wrong but where on where would you play
like why are there not that many out
avenues to do that i'm sure if i you
know dug i would find some sort of like
la county one no i don't know like
underground water pillows yeah yeah i
mean maybe there's no maybe especially
in california but but i never yeah i
never um maybe going to new york right
after i don't know i just never
dove back in the water do you wish the
good place had lasted longer or was it
like
it's time it's the perfect time to end
it i'm a little torn on it because i i
absolutely wish it had lasted longer
like i wish it had lasted for 10 more
years because it was such an ideal
wonderful
truly
good place to work
um but when mike scherz said that it was
he did he he did a thing that i am such
a fan of
that other shows and i don't know bands
or whatever i love it when people like
go out on a high note i love it i think
it is so brave and cool and like
you know not easy to do so
i think if i could um
if i could
rewrite i mean i think i would have
loved for like one more year i wasn't
quite done you know but then but then
it was the four years four seasons yeah
the other side of it is like
when mike told me what the
last season and what the finale
specifically was going to be i really
like
appreciated that he wasn't trying to
fill in a bunch of episodes with like
fluff it really felt yeah ultimately
i am so i'm so on board with with what
we did but
but i just am i guess selfishly but i
just loved it of course and so i guess
it could be both like there's that's
interesting like there's an appreciation
for how he did it and just the theory
behind it and
um
but then there's then there's the self
the part of you that just love doing it
that must be like yeah
just like the day-to-day
i love these people yeah yeah yeah i
love this character yeah it just was um
you know heartbreaking but bittersweet i
guess
and also the emmy i i i don't know if i
knew that when we worked together and
you got nominated for an emmy award yeah
that was pretty wild yeah what is that
like for someone who's never been
nominated for an emmy have you never is
that true isn't that shocking it is
shocking you are so humble
it is shocking
uh well miranda what do you think she's
like you weren't nominated as a guest
star for new girl
ed what about ed no i know but i what is
it what was it like i mean like you're
talking about that makes the whole
journey that you were on
to go from like oh i can't believe i
have this audition to like jesus christ
it really is just
it's such a sweet little hug if that
makes sense that makes sense yeah that's
well said yeah i know what you mean
i mean i know in theory you do though
you know
yeah that was in and you know it was it
came like halfway through this weird
pandemic that we've been having where
things feel so you know depressing and
sad and it was a nice little um it was a
nice little ray of sunshine in a dark
time and
and you know right right yeah right so
it's not it's hard to celebrate that
too yeah
um
i hate to make you do this but will you
just tell i i heard you tell the this
hairy great hairy style story on conan
oh yeah were you i had it made me laugh
so hard will you
if you can sure favor us with a hairy
style story
um
sure let's see
um should i make it quick you were a big
one direction fan which i did not yes so
i think yeah i um
i was a no no i am a big one direction
fan a if a surprisingly big and a
non-ironic one production fan
from the beginning like not not
what was in the beginning
they were
i mean you don't really want to get this
deep with me buddy but they they um they
were on the x factor in england in like
2010.
okay which is a long time ago and i
think that i
actually can't believe i don't know this
number off or this date off the top of
my head but i want to say that i
discovered them in something like april
of 2012.
that's pretty specific actually pretty
close yeah so anyway i mean truly 704. i
could do that by the way i could i could
figure it out because it was it was the
first time i like laid eyes on them was
at
snl when they were um
they were musical guests wait are you
going to joke right now laid eyes on i
almost spit
laid eyes on them laid eyes truly laid
eyes
i didn't even know who they were i'd
never even heard of them and jason my
husband was
working at snl so and you know some of
our friends worked there and i truly was
like who is this like christian boy band
that's i didn't know what they were and
i was so confused as why they were on
snl and then pretty soon into watching
their first song i was like
uh oh
i
think i love them
what's happening did jason witness you
watching them for the first time i think
he did yeah yeah i think he did but it
was i would look jason has said this
before like i understand every weird
part of you but i will never
understand this and he doesn't like make
me feel bad about it or anything but he
is just like i don't i can't quite
understand it
and i think
it's not that different from
maybe
being obsessed with like a football team
or a baseball team knowing all the stats
and the you know names yeah
you know if
in fact you could argue that music is
more valuable than watching guys
throw a ball around right thank you
they're making music yeah yeah
so okay so i mean truly the i'm gonna
make this as short as possible because i
do think i could talk about them for
hours and there's just no need okay so
you know loving them for years one of my
very best friends brandon scott jones
who's another actor and writer he also
loved them so we had this we have this
love together so i wasn't like the only
30 year old that was like loving a a
teenage boy man
um so we would go see them in concert
and we would always go to snl when they
were there and and uh how many concerts
did you see like maybe nine or something
what
that you heard right
i know i know it's re it's really
strange
so i
was
with my little sister miranda ever heard
of her
yes and we were at james corden
he was he was performing at james corden
and a friend of mine who worked there
said come on down to
corydon and you can watch the you know
watch and perform from the side of the
stage and all that stuff which of course
i jumped up the opportune
and um so miranda and i went and watched
it
so so after he performs miranda and i go
to the green room and we're like you
know
we're hanging out in in the backstage
area sort of thing and and he walks in
to
the backstage area and
after a minute he like looks over to me
and sort of like his eyes light up and
he comes over and gives me a big hug and
gives miranda hug and we're chatting and
i i'm like wow i cannot believe he
remembers me he's such a good memory
he's he's sort of he's giving me like
these
really sweet compliments about like what
a good job i'm doing and i'm like oh my
god he watches the good place this is so
nice of him he's so polite and so
he's just such a nice guy which i which
you know he he is and i knew he was and
um and then he you know kind of got
sidetracked and went and talked to other
people and a little later miranda and i
were were chatting together and the and
the stage manager was quieting down the
room by the way i'm i'm over telling
this story at this point but it was
great i love it the the stage manager
was quieting down the room because they
were about to shoot something and um and
harry looks over to me and he's like
he's like what are you guys talking
about
and i was like
nothing like
my friend we're like buddies at this
point like mind your own beeswax
yeah exactly a little bit of sass
and then
he um
he looks at the whole green room and he
says
everybody
sue won't stop talking about this
promotion she got everybody give it up
for sue
she got a promotion big promotion all
right sue like stop talking about it and
and the whole room starts are you saying
it kind of sarcastically yeah he's like
oh god this gal won't stop talking about
her big promotion she's doing so good
and when he says big promotion i'm like
i mean first of all
um
my heart drops i'm like yeah make me
turn into an invisible like get me out
of here
miranda like grabs my leg and we both go
oh
no
just like so quietly like [ __ ]
so
oh man i know feel your pain i know it
and so clearly you know what we
very quickly realize is that
he thinks i'm someone else he thinks i'm
someone named sue someone that just got
a promotion
who knows if she works at corydon or she
who knows who this person is but
so at first you thought it was it was he
was congratulating you on the on the
good place getting picked up you know
what yeah
going back sorry i should have said this
he even said something in that in our
conversation about a promotion something
just like offhandedly about a promotion
which i instantly was like that's
british for second season of good place
that's how british people say you got
picked up for another yeah yeah yeah
yeah or like yeah your series was
promoted
yeah so so when he said sue it was very
clear that he thought it was someone
else
and um
yeah and then it was just like do we you
know what do we do right now do we run
out of this place do i do i tell him
he's wrong
that's a good question that's a tough i
mean
i think i i i'm guessing you just like
laughed and like pretended you were so
then i gotta say like i don't think i
mentioned this on conan he came we
talked a lot more that day
many more times maybe three more times
and he says sue like as too so now you
have to be sued and now i'm just trying
to be as vague and general as possible i
don't want to aim i don't want to
embarrass him i think he has to like
perform again or something you know i'm
like let me
just disappear into a small pile of dust
on the ground like i think i think a hug
goodbye and like it's so good to see you
sue you know like fully to the end
um
yeah
i am aren't you so curious which suit
i'm talking so curious which suit he's
talking about i mean the good news is
and i and and
i mean i would i won't maybe like okay
how do i say this
i'm trying to like
be very cool we've since discussed it
we're
we're good like he is so sweet and so
hilarious about the whole thing
and
that's funny you know like it's been
cleared up one of the like first times i
saw him after telling that story we was
at a at a party and and
he looked at me and he was like hi sue
and then i i was like oh [ __ ] and then
he's like just kidding so he he's all
he's all oh what a charming skin he's
the best he actually truly is
the most wonderful person well that's
good um all right that's so great thank
you sorry if i stumbled over that story
before it no no it's so funny it's also
so i loved when you told it on conan to
use because jason you mentioning jason
reminded me of this because he uh he i
guess he said to you like well now you
have to be sued
that was like the second miranda and i
got in my car i called him and i was
like oh my god let me explain what just
happened and yeah and he said he was
like very calm and he was like you know
what you have to do now right you have
to become sue
it's a really funny yeah
that's so funny that's that's
if that was the only story i'd ever
heard about jason i would know that he
has a that's a great yeah yeah that's
true yeah he is he really is just the
best i
i simply love that guy
yeah
did you hear that jason he's like in the
corner like mention me
he's holding up a sign that's like tell
him how much you love me
we got along great during the pandemic
you've heard that expression luxury
never sleeps i use it daily yeah that's
why you need the real real app we've
talked about the real real a bunch it's
a great way it's very sustainable way to
get the luxury things you like but
without having to pay an arm and a leg
the real reel is the largest and most
trusted source for authenticated luxury
consignment on the app you can shop and
sell top designers 24 7 from anywhere
from your bed from a uh a beach from a
uh anywhere yeah a zamboni if you're
writing anywhere yeah yeah i think um
you know some of your favorite brands
christian well like gucci rolex you
didn't want to pronounce the other one
uh hermes
louis vuitton so all these great brands
up to 90
off retail if you have luxury items that
you no longer use or want yeah the real
real app makes it so easy to sell to one
of
their millions of luxury shoppers so
book an appointment on the app track
your items with your personalized my
sales dashboard and get notifications
when your items sell download the app
today to shop and sell your favorite
luxury brands get 20 off select items
with code real plus new shoppers get 25
off their first purchase available on
the app store or google play get the
real real app today
[Music]
what is your most
would you say
do you use emojis a lot what is your
most common one like your go-to i'm
gonna punctuate this without yeah let me
just think i mean it's probably
like i'm trying to think of which smiley
face it would be mm-hmm i like the
little smiley face that like has the
hands out like kind of about to maybe
hug or grab or something it's like happy
he seems like
yeah he's like
i'm extra happy
hello
yeah that's a little bit yeah a little
pervy well hug or grab is like it's
either like because it's i think i if
i'm not mistaken that emoji is like
blushing
it looks like he's about to honk
something
yes well there's a pervy read on that i
guess if you punctuated like i can't
wait to get my hands on you if it was
like in a more horny context then you
can read it that way and then just a lot
of like i overuse emojis totally i'm
sure like i'm sure in the last text to
you i i i use some emoji i'm just gonna
check really quick did i
okay the last emoji that you and i used
was from you and it was the heart eyes
cat
oh well that was i used that okay hold
on that's a little bit more i didn't
respond
over and over again just
20
20 texts in a row of the heart eyes cat
with no response from me
let me explain um
no because you had said cute love it
which uh
was i thought
i thought it'd be i don't know i thought
a cat hard-eyed cat justin you nailed it
you nailed it we were changing the time
of this podcast you said let's do one
o'clock i said cute love it and you said
cat heart eyes
i love that
and then before that i like your i use i
use the star heart the star eyes
a lot i also use the thinking a lot a
lot i think
like finger to the like
it's funny
when you're like actually questioning
something and it's also fun to use
um in a [ __ ] talking sort of way for
example
maybe
somebody does something that is
questionable and you text your best
friend like so and so said such and such
and then you use the little like
thinking
uh emoji
it's very much so yes huh yeah okay yeah
yeah
yes
it's a ha okay ah thinking about it let
me think about that real quick
yes yeah but then there's its cousin
maybe it's more judgmental cousin with
the monocle
the monocle
yes yes
love the monocle in fact how about this
next time you're talking [ __ ] with your
gals you say the thing and in that text
bubble include the thinking finger guy
and then in the next text bubble almost
immediately give me three
big
monocle guys
oh yeah do you know what i'm saying well
it would have to be worthy of that it
would have to be yeah wait for the wait
for it yeah it's got to be appropriate
i'd want to overuse monaco
if you could be oh now i'm really
curious about this if you could be a
professional athlete what would you play
um i would play water polo yeah
yeah i really love it and i really miss
it
and i was so [ __ ] ripped when i
played it
i bet oh my god
yeah i've heard i've tried to play it
for like at a pool party for like yeah
where i don't even have to tread water
for like five minutes and i'm like yeah
it is kind of crazy to think back on
like the training for that and what a
different you know
we would like hold buckets of water
above our head and shred water can you
even imagine
it's hard to even stick your hands out
of the water and tread water but like
holding something above your head it
would i can't believe that that was wow
and that was the team you were the
captain of and we won we won we won we
won like california state champions it
was you know four for the
maybe it was called northern california
narcal norcal so yeah either way we were
good we were good guys you're so modest
we were good we were good we were good
it was really that's amazing that you
didn't worm that into the previous water
polo conversation we were uh you were
good that's so impressive but you know
like i couldn't i don't have it in me
anymore were your parents athletic um
neither of them
no my dad's a musician and
my parents were more like arty arty
he emigrated from turkey yes he did when
he was young what was was was it under
dire circumstances or was it just uh
you know
it was somewhere in between it was a
little bit of like um my turkish
grandfather fell in love with my great
grandmother
and honey that ain't gonna work
over there at the time so it wasn't it
wasn't like fleeing
per se but it was also like this isn't
going to work in this land you got to go
somewhere else wow wow and they stayed
together they were uh yeah they did they
did very much in love yeah yeah
as far as i could tell when and where's
your mom from she is from uh like grew
up in is that what you mean yeah just
the bay area no no turkey nothing
nothing exciting like that she's she's
just a bay area girl but artistic as
well yeah great like um writer and i
don't think she would claim this but i
think she's a great artist like drawing
artist and just very smart and
thoughtful and
interested and knows a lot about a lot
and is and also
is like almost an encyclopedia when it
comes to like music knowledge she's she
knows she knows everything about
music in my family was sort of
almost like religion or something that
was like our
currency i don't really know how to
explain it that was like what we was it
always um it was always being played
there was uh
they were talking about it a lot what
kind of stuff specifically like 60s 70s
yeah it was like a lot of i mean they
were actually you know in the 80s they
were like uh to use an 80s word like hip
to the 80s music scene so we did listen
to a lot of current music but they were
you know from the beatles to like the
kinks to the band it was a lot of you
know older yeah that's cool did any of
your siblings end up becoming musicians
god it's so crazy that none of us did
why didn't we why didn't we my sister
miranda is a great piano player but but
hasn't played in years so mimo oh i call
her mimo by the way
what do you call it you know what's
funny i'm so glad you said that i was
going to ask you because miranda is a
rel it's not a short short name but it's
three
and three syllables it's long which
i have such a hard time with not a hard
time but i i'm lazy and so i don't like
to say so i shortened the name of all my
brothers to christian's crit my brother
damien's dame yeah and they call me jutt
i was wondering
hold on christian did you say christian
is crit
yeah i love it
yeah not chris i love it good good
that's great that's great
crit and dame that's great yeah who are
you i'm darce
um
laney well we're yeah lainey is
lane
but weirdly her real name is lane and
then laney is the nickname and then lane
has now become the nickname of the the
nickname oh that's funny that's funny
yeah william is will that's easy and
then um miranda is memo nemo how did
that happen that happened
very simply like this
my dad's nickname for her when she was a
wee tiny nothing baby was
mo i guess miranda mo i don't know why
mo happened baby moe
and then her the way she would refer to
herself was like me moe
oh that's really which is pretty cute
and now she's like a full ass grown up
adult married
and we still call her mimo and her you
know like
yeah i think she probably tried to like
shed that at every different new stage
in her life you know like high school
college moving to new york and i would
be like hey mimo
god damn well i i remember an
ex-girlfriend of mine got um
not upset yeah maybe a little frustrated
i don't know how what she got but she
would address this thing that because we
used to we had all these pet names for
each other which is going to sound
nauseating one of them was um at this
point at this time whatever however
couple months i would say uh i would
call her
i called her puppy
cute
puppy and she called me
monkey or i don't know
and i was like i went to pick her up at
a meeting at um
at like
this studio where she was making a move
she was about to like do this big
and it was her first like directing
thing
oh no
and all these producers like
executives and i was like puppy
and she was like ah hi
[Music]
when she said hey don't do that were you
like i cannot believe i did that or were
or were you like questioning your own
motives like why did i do that no no i
got it right away i was embarrassed but
it was also uh
it was so
second nature right it becomes such a it
was weird you know when you were close
to somebody
it was weird to call her by her oh yeah
yeah you know to this day i'm like i i
it feels weird
yes and right now every single person
driving in their car on the stairmaster
wherever they're listening to this
they're like say the name
yeah
uh no because it'd be embarrassing yeah
um puppy but it'd probably be easy to
figure out uh i figured it out mimo yeah
yeah mimo uh uh uh mimo
christian just said to me right because
we do the show together crit said to me
um hey maybe it's time to cause i guess
i forget who i was talking to but i kept
referring to him as
my little brother uh-huh and he was like
let's retire that
yeah yeah
because he's like i'm bigger than you
and um he's like maybe younger brother
right little yeah that is a funny one
little brother is like so not an adult
thing to say i mean it is though because
you just would never change it
it's weird because i've been calling him
that since i was a kid but but yeah
brother
mimo
well she called him doggies oh my god
this person yeah yeah i love this person
yeah nemo uh if meemo i love that well
mimo i hope you're still listening
if nemo stopped listening no she
definitely listens oh if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
you can have one i mean okay i'm trying
to wait i mean i should just answer
really quick the way i'm weighing right
now like is it something that has to be
healthy because it's like the only thing
i'm going to eat for the rest of my life
no no no it does it's like in the good
place yes you're in the good place and
it doesn't the tastiest snack food
pretzel chips like everything pretzel
chips oh you know i love that i love
those yeah yeah they're so satisfying
they are and and because my i was
thinking like oh chips would be great
but i think any major flavor like a
doritos or a sour cream and onion would
get so old but i feel like for
everything
everything pretzel chips yeah should i
say honey mamas i should have said honey
mamas oh well that's another thing we
have in common with paul yeah that's
right uh people should know we're honey
mama i mean where honey mama is we were
the face of honey oh yeah influencers
yeah yeah what is your favorite movie
sequel of all time
i love back to the future three whoa
it's very tied to my childhood like i
actually should when i've re-watched in
my adulthood it's only been the first
one i haven't watched the second or
third one in years
but i remember as a kid loving the third
one and not loving the second one really
bummed me out and the third one i loved
when i was a kid the second one yeah it
got too dark that was really dark yeah
and now and now here we are in
which means you know it's coming in
2025.
the wild wild west baby um what is your
go-to karaoke song i think it's uh
natalie and brook leo's torn
god i love that song i think for so long
i was doing rap songs in karaoke and
then
[Music]
which i still would love to do but i
think i was like let's sing a song you
know
let's commit to singing i'm all out of
faith is that yours i'm all out of oh i
thought that's a real thing uh uh
nothing's wrong
i'm all out of yeah faith
faith yeah
i thought you were cleaning
i had a crush too yeah she's very she's
so like what what year was that ninety
two
thousand
no no maybe earlier i'm sorry i thought
you're right like 99 2000-ish i should
know this because it was a formative she
was a formative figure
the hair and the eyes and just like
pixie pixie manic pixie
yes and let's you know i mean
she's a great singer and i'm sure a
great person but she was very uh i was
like
natalie and bruglia michelle just texted
me in 1997. that's why wow earlier okay
97 yeah 97.
but i but but some people are just
cemented in my mind as being impressive
or beaut or whatever it is yeah like
i've put them i've given them
so much yeah over yeah yeah yeah i mean
and
there were still moments where i was
like
yeah totally yes totally i mean to be
honest like
i i don't think that i had a crush on
ted but i was very aware that my older
sister had a crush on ted and my grandma
had a crush on ted oh
absolutely generational but i knew of
him like from a very young age i knew
that he was like a sex symbol which is
so weird you know
and then yeah yeah so that was a weird
one to sort of wrap my head around
yeah i bet um yeah i remember my mom
like who like
he was somebody i remember my mom before
i even knew
what that was what yeah and by the way
jason and i have watched a ton of cheers
during this panda oh my god and he was i
mean like by the way still is he's
gorgeous he's he's yeah he's non-stop
attractive forever but like he had such
an
a special
like charismatic a tr he was just like i
don't know he's one he's so unique you
know he's unique i think in that he was
he had a a a masculinity like a real
like he was kind of hairy and yeah
jawed and but he was also
non-threatening right he had this kind
of bumbling
innocent like child like there was an
innocence yeah through him totally
that's such a rare um combination yeah
and he truly does still have it it's
like a a manliness that also you know
it's like
the giggle
you know you're like oh he's not just
it was that thing of like him playing
this you know baseball player
i don't know yeah he has he he has the
yeah he has something special i guess
yeah we'll we'll see if his career lasts
um
so i was gonna that's funny the next
question was who was your very first
celebrity crush as fate would have it i
the two crushes that i can remember the
most clearly and and maybe they're
strange but
what the hell is his name um sam wise
from goonies oh uh elijah wood yeah no
but not a little no no not elijah um
oh oh oh oh yes aston oh yeah sean aston
and
yes and then like um alyssa milano from
from who's the boss
samantha
yeah just like my little my little darcy
brain was kind of like why do i like
these guys so much
well that's funny yeah we have very
similar tastes um i won't mention her
name but there's somebody else that we
both have a crush on that
hopefully future guests yes
and then we can talk about gosh i would
yeah that
i mean that would be a very cute meet
cute for you guys
yeah yeah right podcast what was your uh
i hate that term but uh you're meet cute
how did you meet jason jason and i met
um
we met
weirdly
we met at disneyland which is which
sounds oh that's it's cute but we
i was there with
he was there with a group of friends and
i was like the friend from out of town
that was there with like one of the
friends if that makes sense does that
make sense was it a was somebody
deliberately trying to set you guys up
it was just i was in town i was in la
visiting a friend and she was like oh
we're going to disneyland with some
friends from work and and he was there
and he and that's a weird position to be
in to be like the one friend who doesn't
know anybody and he was really
welcoming and nice and warm but also
we i was dating someone else and it
wasn't like uh
i just remember really really liking him
and he like really made me feel included
and he was hot as well and i bet and
it's what he was hoping yeah i remember
being like when i first met him i was
like
uh this guy is too good looking to be my
friend but but like let's see if i can
charm
them yeah it's never happened before
where i've been able to be friends with
a really good looking guy but let's try
it might be this
um if you had to get a tattoo you have
tattoos i had a couple yeah
what was the first one and if you were
to get another one okay what do you
think it would be i haven't had to get
it tonight tonight okay so i have this
one on my arm
and it's for my god the arrows the
arrows so for my three siblings one for
each of them just a little arrow design
that my mom would draw a lot when we
were kids
um and then okay so then i have this one
on my wrist which is a scent sign like
you know a penny a penny one penny a
cent a cent one cent and my dog's name
is penny so that's for penny
um if i had to get one tonight
i mean i truly love just like the the
curse of letter j oh yeah so probably
for yeah for justin for adjusting yeah
what i was gonna say well that's really
flattering no i think um yeah i really
or jason's initials or something there's
just something really pretty about the j
and the c i don't know something for
jason because you know i freaking love
that dude yeah it sounds like it um
that is a pretty
cursive letter j yeah a z i can never do
i always i get scared it reminds me of
billy madison when they like oh that's
right
that's just the lake
maybe i can do zen i'm thinking of billy
madison
um
what is your uh what's your favorite
fruit
uh you just can't
there's nothing like a good writing old
piece of
uh
i mean
i i would say almost every night lately
i eat a
an
asian pear
okay
what are those things
yes yes do i know those things
uh i yes i like asian pears a lot i i
wow every night it's like a uh
they're huge too so i should probably
like like cut them in half or something
but i really like them i'm yeah i'm big
into like apples and asian pears never
met a fruit i don't like you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with an asian pear oh my damn god
that seems so natural it did yes yes yes
i [ __ ] with an asian pear um i wonder
what they call those in asia paris
um
thank you for setting me up like that
who do you want to play
if you did if there's the darcy if yeah
when there's the darcy kardon biopic
who who would you like to play you
they'd be so young now right i mean
right
uh judy garland like what
is it is it like anyone ever what
yeah
i'm realizing that this is one of our
newer questions and i'm realizing it's
slightly it thanks well it's kind of
problematic especially to ask an actor
because it's like well [ __ ] i would play
me right right right you know maybe it's
like because basically it's like okay so
this movie's not coming out for a good
you know let's hope 40 years right
so maybe this person isn't born yet
okay or maybe they're on a nickelodeon
show that i haven't watched
yeah yeah
okay um
so it would be um
the daughter from big little lies
okay
oh i haven't seen it oh yeah you have to
and actually i think her name is darby
so we have oh you know we have a
connection on the first three letters of
our name oh but dara um yeah i just know
darby o'gill oh darby we were killing
the little people yeah i would probably
have darby oh gill and the little people
play oh i'm realizing you have to do a
capital a so it's d apostrophe capital a
that's right and what is your favorite
simpsons character would you kill me if
i said homer no but again um
i'm realizing this is also
a trick probably another question
because he's
well everyone says homer but i mean
immediately i was like i love lisa i
love bart i mean i love them all but
like how homer is that i know the i mean
homer is
so
[ __ ] funny so funny god
um yeah
and you'll ask that question to a lot of
people and they'll be like uh the like
you know the like comic book guy or
whatever and they're lying
well that's so funny you said that i
love the comic that would be my but i
would say yeah if i could pick one as
you don't love him more than homer no no
i mean the one who's brought me the most
laughs for sure is homer okay maybe
as a side character
maybe that's the question who's your
favorite
simpsons side character not including
the simpsons family the simpsons family
yeah i would say ralphie
oh ralph wiggum ralph wiggum yes yes
yeah also very yeah yeah very funny the
one who um
well i i keep thinking about that line
um when he gives her the valentines when
lisa gets the value wait what was that
yeah yes yes
so many good ones like i i i mean gosh
well where are they all in my head right
now but so i mean he he's ralph doesn't
say anything that isn't funny yeah it's
all right just the dumbest sweetest
my milk money
my milk
just constant you know yeah
um and it's funny to
how do i say this
laughing at
stupidity yeah
fun you said it right i think
yeah it's funny i was trying to say
delicately and politely and but then you
said laughing at stupidity is fun
yeah i just said it yeah uh i guess
there's no way around it but it's got to
be obviously the the other there are
conditions that have to be right that's
right he he doesn't know he's stupid
he's very excited he's very happy yeah
that's a really good point the
conditions have to be right um
uh dogs are cats do you prefer ducks
all love to cats but dogs are yeah
the beetles are the rolling stones
beetles but again
love the rolling stones you know yeah
dogs do you have cats favorite beatles
songs song like if you were uh
somebody says oh you want to hear the
beatles and you say did you play could
you please play okay well i don't know
why martha my dear popped into my head
right away but i love him
i love that song too and i and i really
love paul's voice i think the most um
also i don't know why this is i'll never
figure it out but the drums
in magical mystery tour that song
yes they make me cry oh huh it's not a
sad song at all no
but it it overwhelms me almost every
time i listen to it and it makes me cry
i don't know
it's funny that it's not
it's not really like overtly set but
there is like a mournful
quality to that song um
dying to take me away
yeah a little dreamy huh
yeah yeah
oh what a great song what i know it yeah
i mean i i think it's like maybe
cool to hate on the beatles
because i mean maybe what because
they're the most famous band of all time
but
uh i
i absolutely love them like unabashedly
uh no no
shame i love them i love every song i
love every album they like they're they
really like ground me you know yeah me
too no i think maybe people consider it
cool because maybe it's like yeah i
think it's kind of like subversive yeah
to be like because they are so yeah it's
not like um it's like saying you love
friends or something like that it's like
i like i like this you know coffee place
called starbucks it's like
yeah you do everybody does
if if friends were on and seinfeld were
on at the same time which one do you
watch wow that is a tough one that is a
tough one i mean the answer is friends
because i am a crazy friends fanatic
but i i mean you're asking ones that are
this is tough because i i it's like
sophie's choice yeah i mean those are
two of my favorite shows i mean you know
the truth the truth the truth the truth
is
seinfeld might
hold the test of time better so maybe
that would like maybe that would be a
better re-watch i don't know i would be
happy to watch both of those shows you
know and i'm not saying this to be cool
um
i don't
think i've ever
watched a friend's episode start to
finish i i feel like i think i told you
that i think i knew that that somebody's
definitely not proud of it right
somehow this came up when we were
working together and you said that you
you hadn't watched it
and i and yeah and because i kind of
remember saying like
if you were to watch it i think you
would love it but i also don't know that
it fully
holds up i think it does
i i it does for me
yeah you know
is that nostalgia i don't know
then i trust you okay good then start
tonight start tonight i'll give it a
shot yeah there's a few episodes the
good places
um
and would you you're
eating a hot dog
or that kind of type of food you put
ketchup or mustard on it right well it
sounds like it's an either or so i put
catch upon it but you could you would
put both i would go ahead and put both
yeah oh okay wow
um you pat you passed yay you've passed
all you've got a great score i don't
want to tell you the scores it's not a
competition right we're right
um well buddy i'm totally taking
advantage of your your kindness i am so
happy to be talking to you i'm just
going to be a little like cheesy right
now but being a fan of you for so long
and then meeting you and immediately
getting that you were as nice as i hoped
you were and and kind of beyond like you
we just clicked so quickly and you're
such a good truly good person i i'm i'm
really happy we're friends me
me too yeah yeah
i feel like it's weird i know i feel
like i've known you for a long time when
you said like yeah we met a few months
ago i know yeah it's weird i know
friends for life
yeah for sure um i i just adore you i'm
crazy about you um
thank you for doing this thanks for
having me
[Music]
so
so
that that happened is that darcy
i don't know she's god you're making a
uh you're doing a thing with your face
well she has an expressive she's got a
real expressiveness to her
and a calm and a very calming voice
she's a wonderful voice she's a soothing
voice soothing yeah
soothing she's an expressive actor maybe
that's what i'm thinking of
but yeah in terms of uh yes she's a very
calming presence too you would really
like her you would
i i bet i would yeah i can see you guys
getting i like the conversation it's
weird that you haven't known each other
very long but it really seems like you
have i so rarely and it's funny my paul
might be the last example of this i so
rarely meet people
and i think
i know i can be friends with this person
for a long time hopefully forever but
like
that used to happen to me
every couple of months i would say not
to
i hope that's not like a social brag or
something but like i you know when
you're younger you meet people every
god i would just i would think that
often and now it is it happens
so rarely where i'm like what is that
what is that i think it's a combination
of you don't go out you don't meet as
many people sure yeah but also your
standards have
gotten a little more specific yes with
what type of person you want to
welcome in yes and i also
i think because i had done maybe too
much of that like oh we're going to be
friends and i get excited about somebody
and then you don't follow through
don't follow through and like for
probably for not not that i don't like
them or i mean i meet people all the
time who i really like and enjoy their
company but
to commit to a friendship especially
nowadays have you been following through
with her yeah you text and still text
yeah i sent her a thing you know i sent
her a a cat heart emoji i did i did
recently that was funny that was funny
um i did
she's like let me see what your last
text to me what your last emoji was
and she's like ha a cat heart eyes
that was so misleading i did it as a
joke it was like a tongue-in-cheek emoji
it was like a i i told i said the
context in which i sent it yes
so funny you had like a moment of panic
yeah uh no i sent her we recently texted
about um
asian pears came up again i don't want
to give away the guests because i'm
learning
uh but a future guest no a previous
guest oh right
you're not learning
so this is the second week in a row an
asian pair so matthew mcconaughey's
favorite fruit last week yeah asian pear
asian pear how how funny but of course
nobody what do you call he's like an
asian apple
yeah yeah and we recorded we recorded
darcy earlier of course what are the
odds what are the odds that those two
both great both
two people whose company i really enjoy
i don't think i'm gonna be lifelong
friends with matthew but um
i bet it could be
you'd want to be
i want to be i guess it's not it's more
from his yeah that's that's what's
preventing the
friendship coming to fruition but um but
very different people uh
isn't that funny that fruit can that is
very strange yeah also a pretty obscure
fruit
it is it's like it is it's not like uh
you know blueberry i know like or
apple like asian pear it's very specific
i know and i bought one the other day i
think mostly to
do a video i took a little video for
darcy to do like a dumb bit
and um but i was also excited to eat the
asian pear because i've been hearing so
much about it i don't know if i've ever
had an asian pepper i i i
stunned i can't believe that
that's stunning to you yes yeah there
like you said it's not an uncommon
fruit you've had like dragon fruit have
you ever had star fruit it is uncommon
you think an asian pear yeah it's not an
apple or a banana or
an orange they have them they have them
all every time i've been to the girl in
recent memory they have them oh i'm sure
they have them
but it's not like one of the standard
fruits well it comes often in a fruit
salad too especially like a you know
fancy oh it does yeah maybe i just get
fancy fruits maybe
i had one the other day though the one i
bought they're juicy they are supposed
to be this one i had was uh pretty
tasteless it wasn't great it didn't it
wasn't ripe enough yeah i guess so yeah
it wasn't uh
speaking of tasteless fruit
i don't know if you realize you do this
but every time you ask this is a new
question
relative that's the third week we've
done this new question where
you asked the guys i know you're going
to say what can i do our fruit is yeah
yeah see if you know so you're going to
say
for some reason i always um put like add
the sentence you're afraid you got a
nice right piece what yes i don't know
why and you make it like almost sexual
sounding you're like all right you got
yourself all right um you just want to
dig into
i know it's so gross why can't you just
say what's your favorite fruit i don't
know you know what it is i think i don't
know it sounds so simple simple yeah i
know and if there's a translation you
you like get nervous and try to dress it
up
yes gotcha you're walking down the
produce yeah yeah i know i don't know
why i do that yeah nice right peace out
yeah yeah you just wanna dig right in
and sink your [ __ ] teeth
gross you want what what type of juices
would you do it is great it is like
skating down that's what it sounds like
to me it's so foul
i know all right well duly noted
um also
you said um it was very sweet her
relationship that she has with her
sister they seem to remember yes get
along and um
she has miranda yeah miranda and she has
tattoos of all her um siblings the
little arrows to represent and i'm
wondering why you don't have one for me
and second part of the question i have a
mole that i can assign to you oh okay
i'll take that
also you said we're um two years apart
and we're three and a half years i said
we're two years apart yeah no no i think
i was probably talking about damian
that's not what you said though oh
really uh-huh sorry you guys talked
about your dainty wrists
yeah and i was wondering i forgot about
it when she hurt herself
what happened she did you see she's like
i hurt my wrist did she press into
something um
i'm trying to remember uh no she like
she moved it weirdly i think i think she
just moved it
i do remember um not
registering that she had like been in a
position to hurt it you know so it's
almost like it happened out of nowhere
like but she was moving and i think she
was just
like maybe she was picking something up
but it wasn't it didn't look it she
certainly wasn't like pushing herself up
weird supporting her body or anything
weird i know first podcast injury oh
yeah uh hopefully last hopefully
that one direction story is so funny oh
isn't that great i know i hesitated a
little bit to ask her because she had
you know she'd already told it on
so what it's a good story yeah and and
but i'm glad i did i'm saying because
she then um added things to it that she
hadn't included that were really funny i
couldn't believe what a fan she is of
her but i realized then that i guess i
don't really know their music i don't
either they might be really good both
have to not be familiar with one
directions musical ubra
[Laughter]
oh my god
i couldn't tell you i'm not saying this
proudly it's a big band i should know
this i'm sure if i heard one and someone
was like that's one direction yeah i'm
sure i'm sure there's a handful of songs
that i'd be like oh of course i know
that song yeah um i am surprised you've
never seen an episode of friends from
start to finish i may have seen one with
my ex-girlfriend liked friends a lot and
but i don't remember i don't remember
seeing one from start to finish i don't
think i have i should it's crazy again
i'm not i'm not proud of that especially
since it's like one of our questions
it's like a seminal show i know i know
it's and the other weird thing is like
whenever i have seen
parts of it i've enjoyed it it's not
like i'm turned off by it uh she's right
about the everything pretzel chips
in my opinion by the way um great snack
because she's right as great as doritos
are
you'd get sick of them if that was your
snack
i but everything pretzel it would take a
long time to get so i thought you'd like
that answer it's good it's really good
yeah it's very inclusive and um it's a
sustainable snack um finally
i respect the fact that she
put the apostrophe in her name because
she was such a fan of that uh smashing
pumpkins i know a woman but
i can't imagine
how
annoying
it just a little annoying it must be
i'm just thinking of filling out forms
like at the dmv or anything
having to do with
it just feels like you're giving
yourself a little extra annoying thing
and also spelling it for people i know
um d apostrophe
she must really
like the way it looks or really like
that musician a lot well i thought it
would be worth it it's weird i'd give
her definitely give her credit for it
for committing to it but i know you mean
it's like it's also it sounds like such
a small thing but it's just annoying
enough because because of how small it
is i mean how small the actual
apostrophe is and what if you're just
jotting your name down really quick and
you have to squeeze it in it's like
what's what is that a little blemish
like people might misread you when
you're you know you do one letter
per square like if you're feeling oh
your driver's license or you have to
write do you have to put an apostrophe
in its own square that's a good question
probably
yeah i bet for or like you know you're
filling out one of those past those uh
flying overseas or something and filling
out something like that and the computer
doesn't register it and then they kick
you back to the beginning of the thing
what would you do if your kid came to
you you named your kid um lashon yeah
lashon
l apostrophe s-e-a-n well how else would
you spell lashon l apostrophe s-h-a-w-n
i'm thinking of um you know like
debrikashoff ferguson mm-hmm uh former
former player for the new york yard jets
yes um great player why would it have
been
it would have been easier if it just
been dip
d e
apostrophe that's what would replace the
apostrophe yeah it would be like dab
debris debris
yeah
instead of debris
but i guess i don't know hey if she
likes it she likes it yeah
i know i wouldn't like it it looks
classy it looks cool it does look cool
darcy christian yeah but you know what's
funny it it um it betrays how like kind
of normal and casual she is it does yeah
she seems like a very she's a person no
not at all not an apostrophe person yeah
is darby o'gill in the little people
apostle darby i don't know i've never
heard that
ever in my life you haven't no and you
said it like
it was a thing that everyone knows
you've never heard no darby o'gill in
the little people there's a disney movie
we watched it doesn't even ring a bell
oh really i think it's a very old movie
i think maybe darby o'gill in a little
bit yeah i haven't seen it you know
what's funny i'm now thinking i haven't
seen it since i was like maybe five
which means you probably don't have
memories of it and slash may not have
seen it okay darby o'gill in the little
people i forget what's about a cool name
yeah i think it's about i think it's
kind of like a um gallopers travels
situation
that's how they pitched it
okay so this is like a gulliver's travel
situation
d-a-r no apostrophe
um
there's no apostrophe i don't know
that's what i'm wondering oh
we could google it
google it justin it's funny i was trying
to think of other d apostrophe names is
it things to give apostrophes to like d
words don't don't overthink it
um let's
read a letter
oh cool the new printer yeah i got a new
printer boss cool
yeah uh i'm surprised that word hasn't
come back yet to as a um synonym maybe
it just did yes boss okay
uh this is from catherine brewer subject
a bone to pick uh oh and uh would you
rather did you hesitate yeah it was it
uh initials yup w-i-r-w-y-r
i can't say it i don't know why why i
want to say ywr
a bone to pick in a white and a w-i-r
see
weird hi justin christian i am a long
time listener proud to say that i've
listened to every episode oh thank you
catherine brewer
i am a traveling in-home pediatric
speech language pathologist
wow cool during this pandemic i continue
to do face-to-face therapy for my
clients and you too certainly ease the
anxiety between visits as i am traveling
place to place however
i do as my subject line says have a bone
to pick with you playfully of course oh
good
i prefer playful bones
being picked i love your lightning
rounded questions and how you have been
editing them along the way but
it's not what i would necessarily call a
lightning round this is true she's right
maybe it should be called something else
i get a little chuckle as justin asked
the question and then asks three three
or four more follow-up questions after
that because he is just so truly and
genuinely interested in the guest
response it just doesn't seem to go at
quote lightning speed
and one of those emojis they're like ah
the one that's like la a big smile and
like squinting eyes what is that big
smile like this one this one
uh i know you're talking about it i
wouldn't know how to describe it though
but i do enjoy those questions how about
would you rather well
let's just address that she's right i
mean yeah except for katie couric she
answered those lightning lightning speed
some people do some people take that
more literally okay how about it would
you rather would you rather be playing
with a small child
would you rather be playing with a small
child sitting in your lap and realize
you have poop on your clothes and not be
able to change for the rest of the day
or
would you rather be playing with a small
child sitting in your lap as they
continue to sneeze in your face without
covering their mouth and you aren't
quick enough to dodge it and have no
access to any tissues or wipes
okay so the first one is child's play in
your lab you realize you've pooped on
your clothes and i'm assuming it's a
child's poop
yeah okay
uh you can't change it can we for the
rest of the day can we pick an age for
how old the child is yeah i'm sure small
child but can we settle
what age would that be
playing your lap but probably like 12
months oh yeah because if they're any
older
you'd be able to talk to it and like
explain that it has to
cover it
i'm taking this too literally i don't
understand why the poop you can't get
rid of the poop but maybe
you just can't for whatever reason yeah
so it's let's say it's a 12 month old
child uh-huh
um you know i would pick i'd pick the
poop i would too
i mean it's gross of course well it's
not it's also not that gross that's why
i asked about the age because there's a
pretty huge difference between
baby poop and yeah toddler poops like
poop from my
experience yeah the viscosity changes
the smell radically changes yeah that's
true when it's like infant poop is not
bad it's just because it's like it's
like formula yeah
um god it's like butt form how many
it's not it's just been like slightly
processed yeah it's like sour milk
smelling ugh i wonder how many
listeners we just left but the um the
sneezing is also kind of cute you know
when babysitting is so cute it's not
like a big like gross person oh no they
like surprise themselves and they're
like yeah it's really funny
then you think during covid the idea of
being around any age
human being sneezing in your face is
like yeah really so turns me off you
know what i think i picked the poop um
i'm now just picturing like little kids
sneezing it's so cute when they're like
when you go and they laugh afterwards
when you get like turn it into a funny
thing and they go and they get like have
that surprise leg and you go what was it
yeah the truth is i i don't really
really pick the sneeze i don't really
mind either i don't want to poop on me i
pick a sneeze why not i don't mind
sneezing what if they have covered
oh well they oh i'm guessing they don't
okay
doctor okay well if they have covid and
you're playing with them in your lap all
day sneeze or gnosties you're probably
gonna get it that's true um also poop
probably has coveted in it
poop on your clothes okay doctor hi okay
we should ask dr dave
really important question uh and then
back to catherine she says i have tried
to base these with your other questions
from true experiences and this is a
crying laughing face
i am so happy to continue to listen to
your podcast in the new year and cannot
wait to see what the new year has to
bring for the two of you wishing you all
the best in 2021 catherine what a nice
thanks catherine brewer yeah what a nice
catherine brewer uh okay well and thanks
to our guest darcy oh also if you guys
would like to write in
uh we really enjoy getting your letters
and you may send them to
life is short at wondery.com and i often
say this and um don't completely mean it
the way i do now to my new friend
tarcy so happy darcy darcy did you say
tarcy no tars maybe i'd maybe i didn't
hit the d that did did it hard enough
darcy um
what a what a great thing that happened
in 2020 you know people are what well no
no that particular thing oh me meeting
darselfie
i got to meet darcy you know other
things happen in 2010 don't get me
started okay um so thanks to my pal
darcy and um thanks to all of you for
listening
my uh
virtual pal
um it's a very one-sided relationship i
guess but not when we get nice letters
like kathryn yeah and uh we'll see you
next week don't be strangers
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you question long
christian long what did i say christian
law i was so thrown by the fact that i
got that right another producer on this
one is megan monaco and senior producer
is michelle miesh lands with the audio
engineer being sergio enriquez when it
comes to executive producers marshall
louie and hernan lopez for a company
that many people most people call
wondery
[Music]
when christian and i had the idea to
ask our grandma jody to be a guest on
our podcast it was
kind of a selfish move because while we
love her and and think she's hilarious
and and has such a great take on things
and obviously there was a very selfish
interest in our own personal family
history we really thought that um it'd
be one that fewer people tuned into i
hate saying that
but it's just just the nature of a show
like this uh
you know the more known the guest is the
more people tune in and and
she was very known to us but nobody
outside of you know a few
of her friends and family knew her um
and uh as it turns out the grand
majority episode was the one that
listeners the show referenced the most
the one that we got by far the most the
the best feedback from and it was
obviously our favorite but it turns out
to be um
a lot of people's favorite and i think
we just underestimated how charming and
appealing and fun to
talk to she was and um
she i know she was for us but it turns
out she was for a lot of people and so
uh
for um
yeah i know for any of you who have lost
someone close to you
understand the idea of her absence is is
a very difficult thing
to wrap our heads around it's an
impossible thing to wrap our heads
around because just such a presence in
our lives
but christian and i want you all to know
how much we appreciate your letters and
your kind words about jody
and she really
you should know she would love doing the
show and and
she would be laughing now if she knew
that strangers were
mourning her um
i can hear her
uh
and she she'd lived a long life she
lived to be 104 and um
we just got spoiled because she was so
healthy and surprised you could hear we
recorded that about a year ago
but she i'm comforted to know that she
had become comfortable with the idea of
dying uh
and since we were so entertained by her
i thankfully have so many more
recordings of her so
she'll continue to be a big part of the
show because um
this show is a big part of our lives and
so is
so is grandma jody
and she always will be so
her death i think it's just a reminder
to enjoy the people
you love
who are here as much as possible and um
like jody just to remain
curious and present and compassionate
and
she was all those things and to laugh a
lot um because she did
um
because even if you live to be 104 life
is short
but with the right grandmother it can be
a lot more fun
and we're going to miss our favorite
guest
so thanks for listening